horizon zero dawn guerrillas ambitious
open-world game is finally out in the
wild and it's pretty damn cool if you've
made it to the desert by now you've
probably gotten a taste of some of the
bigger deadlier machines the game has to
offer if you're getting your ass kicked
in the early game check out our
essential tips video and make sure to
subscribe for more on horizon
but if you're looking for an edge on
taking down some of the most dangerous
machines then look no further
before we get into the nitty-gritty
let's get some of the basics out of the
way first make sure your medicine pouch
is topped off even if you are over
leveled one well-placed hit can knock a
LOI on her ass make sure to have potions
ready and an ample supply of tare blast
and hardpoint arrows if you don't know
if those are then you might want to buy
a new bow by now you should have the
hunter reflex and concentration perks
but if you don't unlock them I'd also
recommend concentration plus and fast
reload and remember it's smart to
checkout the Machine catalog or scan it
with your focus before going toe to toe
with one of these behemoths now that
we're all stocked up on supplies let's
lay some machines Sarah Connor style
we're gonna kick this off with the rock
breaker one-on-one these guys aren't too
tough unfortunately apart from a side
quest I've yet to find one of these
things alone they usually come in pairs
and if you aren't constantly moving and
checking your surroundings you won't
last long when you engage a pair of rock
breakers keep your eyes on the ground
you should see dirt flying up in the air
as they burrow around the battlefield
keep rolling into one of these creatures
reveals itself once they're out in the
open you have a few options you can
shoot its arms disabling its ability to
dig you can destroy the fuel sack
disabling its ranged attacks or you can
shoot the exhaust vent I typically don't
go for the arms because you have to
destroy all four in order to stop the
rock breaker from digging however if the
opportunity to shoot the fuel sack
arises I'd recommend lodging a few
well-placed hardpoint or precision
arrows in its stomach because its range
attacks can be deadly and tough to avoid
this leaves the exhaust port I focused
most my fire here because it deals a
hefty bit of damage and it's a
relatively easy target to hit once
you've eliminated the first rock breaker
the second shouldn't be too tough
next let's take a look at the storm bird
these things are deadly somewhat common
and tough to hit if you've spent more
than a few hours in a desert there's a
good chance you've run into one if
you're still using a basic bow I'd avoid
this confrontation altogether however if
you're feeling brave there are some
techniques that can ground these birds
first you'll need to take out its
lightning gun with a tear arrow or two
these machines can carpet the
battlefield with electricity and fire
devastating balls of energy after that
stun wait until a bird lands when it
touches down pin it to the ground with
the rope castor and aim for its blaze
canisters with your fire arrows by now
you should know what happens when you
set one of these puppies ablaze in most
cases though that won't kill it from
here
I either aim for the freeze canisters
located on its shoulders or the engines
on its wings work it down a little more
and the storm bird should fall a quick
side note when you are fighting a storm
bird it's easy to focus on what's above
you rather than what's around you this
makes it easy for smaller machines to
get in your way so be careful
finally let's take a look at the Thunder
job
if you've been watching trailers and
demos of horizon you'll probably
recognize this bipedal machine it's
probably one of the toughest machines to
take down in the game it has a couple
weak points but getting to them can be
kind of tricky so make sure you have
tear blast arrows ready before you
engage once you find yourself staring
down one of these things I'd aim for all
of your little toys disable the disc
launcher knock off the radar and rip off
its cannons these machines have a wide
range of moves so blowing off its
weapons can eliminate a lot of its
strategies but that's never enough fire
a tear blast
arrow right in its noggin to reveal its
data Nexus this is a little square chip
that if hit directly deals a lot of
damage the catch is that it's on top of
its head so unless you have high ground
or the Beast is looking down it can be
difficult to hit if you're having
trouble hitting that you can aim for
either side of its neck with a tear
blast arrow to reveal its heart the
heart is a bit tougher to get to but
it's bigger and deals slightly more
damage after a few dozen well-placed
shots in one of its weak points the
Thunder jaw should crumble but once
again be wary of outside interference
because you don't want to get
overwhelmed
[Music]
those are three of the toughest machines
you'll find in the wild and there are
plenty more strategies to take these
down make sure to keep your medicine
pouch stocked up and your Quivers full
and you should be good to go if you want
to see more horizon subscribe and be
sure to check out our new show reboot
it's a weekly editorial show with full
episodes every other Sunday and a Q&A
with Mike McCarty and myself in the off
weeks good luck out there hunters and as
always thanks for watching